Один долар за паспорт та ідентифікаційний код,
20 доларів - за банківську інформацію з номерами карток і навіть ключовим словом,
35 доларів -  і дані про перетин кордону більше не таємниця.
Номери мобільного телефону, емейли, домашні адреси українців у відкритому доступі
-  взагалі задарма.
Усі ці дані можна отримати кількома кліками в телеграм-каналах.
Чим це загрожує, відчув на собі підприємець Валерій Яковенко.
Скориставшись його документами, шахраї взяли позику 10 тисяч гривень.
Це було несподіванкою для мене.
Дізнався я про це випадково, коли до мене вже прийшло повідомлення, що є заборгованість.
Я побачив це повідомлення і подумав, що це чийсь жарт, а виявилося, що насправді
хтось отримав кредит на моє ім’я і на мої документи.
Зв’язатися з фінансовою компанією, що видала кредит, у Валерія не вийшло
і він написав про свою проблему у соцмережі. Ситуацію вдалося владнати вже наступного дня.
Однак постраждав бізнес Валерія.
Він пов’язаний з безпілотними технологіями і вимагає постійних інвестицій.
Через позику, взяту без відома підприємця, на деякий час було зіпсовано його кредитну історію,
а відтак зникла довіра банків.
У мене анулювані всі мої кредитні ліміти, тобто всі гроші,
які я мав можливість отримати з банку,
це гроші персональні, це гроші на покупку техніки і т.д. - вони зникли,
тобто у мене повністю зникла можливість будь-якого фінансування.
Навіть якщо ви довели свою правоту, що ви нікому нічого не винні,
що ніякого кредиту не було, банки оновлюють свою інформацію не одразу,
а лише раз на тиждень, два, три чи навіть місяці.
Окрім оформлення так званих мікрокредитів, маючи копії документів,
шахраї можуть вчинити махінації з майном чи навіть шантажувати людину.
Нині ж найлегшим способом отримати персональні дані про особу
є анонімні телеграм-канали.
Користувачам вони пропонують безкоштовно базову інформацію про громадян України
на кшталт номеру телефону чи адреси проживання.
За підписку, що коштує від 350 до 2000 грн можна отримати сканкопії документів
чи навіть банківські дані та інформацію міграційної служби.
Адвокат Олександр Тананакін задля експерименту перевірив,
як це працює і яка інформація про нього доступна в мережі.
Я купляв свої дані. Ну, по-перше, ці дані, вони не те що персональні,
це банківська таємниця, тобто це дані про клієнта банку.
Я продемонстровував, що це легко зробити за 20 доларів.
Сплачуєте гроші, через 2 хвилини вам надсилають у зворотньому повідомленні
такий витяг з анкети клієнта банку.
У моєму випадку це була фотографія з карткою,
анкета відносно мене, в якій зазначені всі мої дані і навіть секретне слово.
Чат-бот в месенджері, через який Олександр купував інформацію про себе, було заблоковано.
Якщо вірити адміністраторам цього телеграм-каналу,
вони володіли базами даних державних реєстрів,
соціальних мереж та приватних компаній.
Загалом у розпорядженні чат-боту були сотні мільйонів документів.
Засновник платформи Hacken, яка об’єднує так званих "білих" хакерів з усього світу,
Дмитро Будорін знається на вразливих місцях різних систем і реєстрів.
Він припускає, що у більшості випадків витік персональної інформації з державних реєстрів
та приватних баз даних трапляється не через втручання хакерів,
а за участі людей, що мають до неї санкціонований доступ.
Треба розуміти, хакери всі ліниві.
Зламати якусь систему, ось так саме по-хакерськи, це часто довго,
має бути належна підготовка, технічні навички.
Тому хакери завжди намагаються знайти легший спосіб.
Якщо потрібна якась база, шукається список співробітників підприємства,
знаходиться підхід до них, пропонується 100-200 доларів,
100 доларів аванс, 200 за отримання інформації, і доволі швидко отримується ця база.
У Міністерстві цифрової трансформації погоджуються -
проблема з державними реєстрами дійсно існує.
Їх наразі - 350, у кожному зберігається значний об’єм персональних даних українців.
Кажуть, забезпечити захист і проконтролювати доступ до кожного практично неможливо.
Водночас звинувачення у витоку даних з мобільного додатку "Дія",
що дає доступ українцям до електронних версій їхніх документів, категорично заперечують
і називають не інакше, як інформаційними атаками на Мінцифри.
В принципі там не може бути масового витоку, бо там запит по одній людині.
Навіть якщо теоретично уявити - що насправді неможливо, - що хтось отримав доступ до "Дії",
то там не можна викачати не десятки, не сотні, не тим паче мільйон даних.
А в боті, ви бачили, там було понад 20 мільйонів.
Всі запити, які відбуваються між мобільним застосунком "Дія" і реєстрами,
там подвійні, а в окремих випадках навіть потрійні відбуваються шифрування.
Кіберполіція регулярно проводить обшуки та знаходить зловмисників,
які накопичують та продають персональні дані громадян.
Частково правоохоронці звинувачують у цьому самих українців, які через низьку кібергігієну
часто залишають зайву приватну інформацію, реєструючись на різних ресурсах.
Очільник департмаменту кіберполіції Олександр Гринчак каже,
що продаж баз персональних даних існує багато років.
Раніше основним майданчиком діяльності для шахраїв був дакнет,
тепер вони перемістилися у анонімні телеграм-канали.
Що стосується документування телеграм-каналів, це проблематика усього світу
і таких відомств, як наше, у багатьох розвинених країнах світу.
Але є інструменти щодо ідентифікації таких осіб, і саме розслідування і встановлення осіб,
які є причетні до вчинення даного правопорушення
зі створення такого телеграм-каналу потребує дійсно значного часу.
На думку експертів з цифрової безпеки,  на практиці відшукати,
хто саме стоїть за анонімними телеграм-каналами та з’ясувати,
звідки вони черпають персональні дані, вкрай складно.
Відтак ця інформація й надалі буде у відкритому доступі.
Тому кожному українцю варто власноруч подбати про захищеність своїх даних.
Серед іншого треба звести до мінімуму заповнення анкет,
які часом просять державні і приватні компанії.
Так само варто подбати про надійні паролі до пошти і віртуальних дисків,
де зберігаються копії ваших документів.
Я би радив, якщо ви помітили свої дані, хоча би в електронному вигляді
подати якусь скаргу, запит в правоохоронні органи, для того, щоб зафіксувати цей факт
Якщо людина йде отримувати, наприклад, посилку, то замість паспорта як підтвердження
використовувати наприклад водійське посвідчення або авторизацію через смс-паролі,
щоб дані ваші не потрапляли в руки персоналу, в об’єктиви камер тощо.
За несанкціонований збут або розповсюдження інформації з обмеженим доступом
законодавством передбачений штраф від 8500 до 17 000 гривень або два роки у в’язниці.
Але поки кіберполіція заблокувала телеграм-бот з персональними даними і розслідує їх витік,
декілька інших каналів у месенджері пропонують аналогічну інформацію.
Тим часом "білі" хакери прогнозують збільшення кіберзлочинності у світі в 2020 році на 150%.